welcome to this video playing tall
stroke Todd stoop from Denmark maybe
that one London system stung okay so
maybe you will take on f4 nope
interesting okay and the interesting way
to play night early on to g6 okay seems
he wants to play with efile maybe I
should stop that right in its tracks
it's not so clear what all those pieces
are doing directed at the e5 square when
you can never play that more 92 yo let's
start with that wow he's just shutting
things down
you are trying to arrest them a little
bit with a four a five
ok and now e5 or do I have something
better hmm I mean 95 of course what do I
have something ups do I have something
better I can also know I was thinking
I'd g five pts Knight f6 all of the time
ok let's put the knife down he has a
hard time to capture it with any office
nights because his pieces are trapped
boys bishops trap let's say yeah so we
had to take with the bishop ultimately
yeah I guess that one and now I think
Queen age five should be ok for Knight
f3 95
yeah why does a bit better in this
position okay i have no choice have to
check and no 95 is closed
so what's a cool defensive move so how
do I continue after that hmm the i-95 s
goes he goes age six and that leads
nowhere Bishop each form is getting the
Queens of the broad okay maybe this
moved to prepare g4
I is fairly solid yeah its own oh no
it's not so solid anymore on the dark
squares but okay if the problem is I
have no good square for my queen pretty
much have to allow a queen trade okay so
I need to do something here when the
Queen side that's the only idea left
that same well it's an interesting
moment I can take one is six that's an
interesting way to play
okay come on let's do that it's I'm not
sure how good it is but it's interesting
it's definitely definitely worth trying
getting three Pawn cm
and that's a fairly good position I
think d 6 I mean fairly good is very
conservative maybe I'm just in good
shape but I tend to be too optimistic so
I try to tone down on that oops so it's
kidding okay we're giving something back
immediately okay keep the pawn seagoing
rook da door something it's an OD 600
that's go 36
check
so what to do I guess h4 to keep my to
keep my map Bishop down now trying to
trying to use my pawns ultimately check
okay
adds I mean rook endgames always have
some drawing tendencies but this is too
much
hmm rookie 17-6 check that's a cute move
time warning
I still cannot activate his rope due to
the pawn on the seventh rank check
black resins jam interesting yay around
here I think like Isis kind of okay cat
tried those things here interesting
moment is when I took only six match so
here and now I went c4 kind of last last
attempt to deduced to do something yeah
and I think probably that's no good
right yeah night takes the success
winning according to the engine yeah I
should take on and be okay I guess
doesn't seem anything wrong with that I
wanted to go rook c1 one of the two and
then just recapture that but the engine
is giving giving this kind of thing and
then c5 and black is okay yeah yeah that
was set was what he should have done but
this is in fact really good for wide and
rook see 10 is essentially winning it's
it's a bit too much I've got three pawns
and I was pawn mass is his sis it's just
very strong d 6 is a threat and so on
his nights I'm not doing anything so
that was um yeah it's only big mistake
they're playing age six otherwise he was
completely okay okay well thanks for
watching